shea brennan is a formidable presence on
the prairie and yellowstone prequel
1883. but what about the man with the
mustache who plays him sam elliott
boasting an impressive cast including
sam elliott tim mcgraw faith hill
isabelle may and lamonica garrett 1883
is the origin story of yellowstone
including how the dutton family acquired
the largest cattle ranch in the united
states it's a tale that follows the 19th
century duttons as they travel west on a
wagon train through harsh environmental
conditions encountering hostile enemies
at every turn what is 1883 going to
bring to the fans what are they going to
get out of this show i think we're going
to get a really good classic period
western
fans of the original yellowstone series
have been clamoring for more screen time
in the 1800s ever since the season 4
premiere of yellowstone featured a brief
glimpse of tim mcgraw's james dutton
negotiating with the tribe of native
americans regarding the family's
ranchland not the one that took it from
doesn't matter
still got took
[Music]
you're trying to take it back
while plenty of country music fans are
probably excited to learn more about the
patriarch and the matriarch of the
dutton family as portrayed by mcgraw and
hill the two country music stars are far
from the only recognizable faces in the
upcoming series leading the pack is
elliot as hardened cowboy shay brennan
who never rides without his trusted
partner thomas the two have formed a
strong bond both on-screen and off
what's it really like working alongside
a living legend like elliot during a
round table interview that included
looper garrett confirmed what we
suspected all along about the seasoned
1883 star
you coming
[Music]
i'm thinking about it
speaking about his 1883 co-star lamonica
garrett said sam's a great dude he
embraced me from the first time that we
met and he calms the nerves of everyone
that he comes in contact with garrett
points to elliot's steadiness and work
ethic as part of what makes 1883
must-see tv as garrett put it elliott is
the first one there and the last one to
leave he also added quote he's inspiring
to watch he's a great person and a great
actor
y'all just sit up here and watch you
look like you had it figured
even fellow actors like garrett get
starstruck on set sometimes by just
being in the presence of elliot who has
previously starred in such westerns as
the quick and the dead tombstone and
justified among others during the
interview garrett shared that he
sometimes gets caught up in watching
elliot work when he's sharing a scene
with him previewing a scene in the third
episode of 1883 he shared there is a
scene coming up in episode 3 of 1883
where he gun butts one of the immigrants
i had the next line and there was some
action that was about to happen and i
caught myself looking at him like wow
that's how virgil gun-butted ike in
tombstone it was the same motion and i
was like snap back into reality it's
time to work right now and fortunately
everything seems to indicate that
garrett's strong feelings of admiration
for elliot are entirely mutual in a
recent interview elliott also praises
his co-star and on-screen partner in
fact elliot has only good things to say
about the process of developing the bond
between the two characters elliot says
quote it feels totally natural to me
referring to his and garrett's
characters as brothers in arms the
roadhouse star also notes that he thinks
thomas and shea's close friendship could
have potentially been more difficult to
sell given the racial politics of the
time period in which the series is set
he said it speaks volumes about both of
these characters that are traveling with
him a guy from a totally different race
in a period of time when you would think
that i don't know about that i'm not
sure i believe that but that
relationship lamonica's one of my
favorite elements of this entire thing
elliot recalled of working with garrett
when i get with lamonica and i look at
those eyes and i look at that mass that
is underneath that hat of his and listen
to that voice he's rock solid he's
always rock solid in every bit of this
stuff i just love working with the man
good show
yep
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
yellowstone are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]